the morning of October 9th fragments of
a Hamas missile land less than a mile
outside of benguan airport Israel's main
International Airport on the ground
passengers ran for
cover in the skies above a ryion air
flight on approach diverted away and yet
in a matter of minutes aircraft resumed
taking off and landing at the airport
while the war continued despite it being
less than 40 miles from the front lines
of Israel's war with Gaza beneran
airport has remained open throughout the
conflict and while civil airspaces above
War zones like Ukraine often remain
closed from the moment War breaks out
Israel's civil airspace has continued to
receive commercial traffic I think the
key question here that everyone's asking
is why haven't the Israelis closed their
airspace and I think the answer is
countries are always going to air on the
side of keeping it open so how does
Israel keep an airport open in a war
zone and what are the risks to aircraft
in the
airspace keeping airspace open can
provide a vital Corridor for Israel to
allow people to leave soldiers to return
and goods and supplies to continue
entering the country during the conflict
one of the steps the country has taken
to try and protect those aircraft is to
change the route they're approaching
benguan from the main mitigation measure
that we've taken is completely
separating the roots from the area of
the conflict The Roots basically in and
out of Israel are much Northern than
they are usually going 10 miles south of
hia according to Israel's civil aviation
Authority the country's civil and
Military air traffic controllers also
work very closely together and often sit
in the same buildings and look at the
same aerial
picture and that allows them to
coordinate on trying to ensure that
missiles from the country's Iron Dome
system don't impact civilian aircraft
when they're intercepting Hamas missiles
it still leaves plenty of flexibility
for the defense systems to uh plan their
engagement to plan their their
interception of of an a rocket on the
ground while benguan airport can
normally have over 10 aircraft waiting
at its Gates we've limited the number of
aircraft that are loaded with passengers
and with fuel so you would see maximum
six normally four and when the aircraft
are ready to depart takeoff is as Swift
as possible with no queuing on the
runway Israel's civil aviation Authority
says that part of the reason it's able
to keep its airspace open is because it
has remained open previously through
years of Hamas missile attacks so no one
is doing anything new civil aviation
doesn't like doing new stuff not in
general and specifically not in conflict
and that's why the country issued a
notice to Airlines saying its airspace
would remain open but the airlines
should use caution a notice the FAA and
aasa its European equivalent have also
sent out yet despite this the vast bulk
of international carriers have paused
flying to Tel Aviv while many Alin
stopped flying to Tel Aviv the day Hamas
launched its surprise attack others
continued to fly for a few days more a
British Airways flight actually turned
back moments before landing as Aid
Sirens were sounding in the area
surrounding the airport has issued a
statement saying it suspended all
flights tell until further notice some
owners even though their insurance
allows uh these operations they don't
want it again uh understandable even
though the airspace remains open
Airlines will have many questions to
consider if they operate flights into
the region how frequent is the rocket
fire from from Gaza how deep into Israel
are our Rockets being launched where are
those Iron Dome intercepts taking place
Matt Bor is Chief intelligence officer
and one of the co-founders of osprey
flight Solutions an aviation risk
management company that advises the
likes of America's TSA his job is to
evaluate some of the worst case
scenarios and he thinks that Israel's
airspace should be more restricted the
area where the conflict is affecting
which includes Northern Israel hia Tel
Aviv should be paused until the
trajectory of this conflict becomes more
clear Matt cautioned that even though
aircraft were being rerooted to approach
overh there had still been recent surfac
to- a missile or Sam activity in the
region the IDF has confirmed the
employed a conventional Sam system to
shoot down a rocket launch from Gaza
near hia footage of the impact later
appeared on social media why this is a
concern is because now we're creating
the conditions for a shootdown civil
aviation flying in between areas where
conflict activity is happening Israel
says that when a missile is fired its
air traffic controllers can have over a
minute and a half to maneuver aircraft
out of the area and in that time
aircraft can cover around 10 miles while
neither Hamas nor Israel is likely to
intentionally Target civilian aircraft
according to Matt there's still a risk
that an aircraft could be shot down if
it's misidentified as a missile or other
threat which is exactly what happened
when Malaysia Airlines flight 17 was
shot down over eastern Ukraine by Pro
Russian militia weather caused this
aircraft to deviate from its flight path
which led to the rebel group to
interpret it as not a civilian airliner
because it wasn't flying on the civilian
airliner routes so Osprey has already
told its clients uh that we assess the
potential for
miscalculation or misidentification in
Israeli airspace uh to be likely in the
near term under the current scenario
Israel that misidentification is a major
risk factor in its airspace there are
technical limitations on some of the
systems that again there is no
possibility that an that an Interceptor
could H Target a civilian aircraft if
anyone has a minimal knowledge in in
aviation a screen showing a drone and a
civilian aircraft and a fighter jet
looks very very different and the mh17
and other tragic IAL accidents that
happened have a very very different
background and none of it is is relevant
in this conflict while the situation in
Israel is already complex the addition
of outside forces like Syria and
Hezbollah who have already engaged in
limited artillery exchanges with Israel
could complicate things further do you
trust Hezbollah will not make a mistake
on firing on a Target over Northern
Israel Israel however says that it is
monitoring risks from all sides we're
monitoring very very close closely and
and looking at the risk very carefully
monitoring the situation in Lebanon
monitoring the situation in Syria I can
assure you that if we see many rockets
launched towards benuron we will freeze
traffic and benuron and traffic will go
to elat Ramon as the situation in the
skies above Israel evolves its Aviation
Authority maintains that it will remain
accountable whatever happens we monitor
the situation closely we listen to Intel
we see ourselves as accountable and we
look at this role very very
[Music]
seriously